the Germans have a reputation for being
sensible efficient practical so it's no
surprise that they have a knack for
inventing stuff in fact Germany is the
European champion of inventions pennies
the world cup when you've got a title
like that no country in Europe reports
more patterns each year than German
nearly twenty thousand a year worldwide
only the US Japan and China report more
to be fair they have way more people
ever heard of the mp3 that musical
breakthrough came from Karl Heinz
Brandenburg hands leaders gift to the
world was the gummy bear oh and we have
invented speed of a zoo nakhon to thank
for the hole punch making stationery fun
and let's not forget minute events as a
housewife in Berlin at the start of the
20th century she'd had enough of over
brewed grainy coffee so she invented the
coffee filter it became so popular
she founded a business smashing the
patriarchy and improving breakfast all
in one it's all about products and
patterns some of the best inventions in
Germany are more about attitudes and
simple solutions we've come up with a
list of the best German life facts
things that Germans take for granted but
which the rest of us could really
benefit from here we go
[Music]
picture this you're all cozy snuggled up
in bed with your partner and you drift
off to sleep BAM you wake up shivering
and turn to see your partner wrapped in
some kind of duvet cocoon in a deep deep
sleep you've got no chance of getting it
back for Germans sleep is far too
important to be jeopardized by the
romantic notion of sharing a duvet
that's why in most German homes and
hotels you'll find double beds with two
single duvets trust me once you try it
you'll never go back ever been caught
short when you want to open a bottle of
beer but you don't have an opener to
hand the Germans have found a way around
that by developing a special national
skill for opening bottles with all sorts
of objects the most popular being a
lighter sure we're all keen on saving
the planet but sometimes you need an
extra incentive in Germany instead of
relying on people's guilty conscience is
to encourage recycling they have a
deposit system in place you pay more for
your drink and you have to return the
bottle to get the deposit back it sounds
like a lot of hassle right but it works
returning fund flashin or deposit
bottles is part of most people's weekly
routine this one is specifically for you
North Americans out there don't be
surprised if you visit a German
household and find the whole family
running around in fluffy Footwear in
Germany it's simply the done thing to
switch from outdoor shoes to slippers or
house shoes at the front door
comfortable cozy and a lot cleaner
when you're out for drinks with a group
of people don't you just hate that
awkward moment when the bill comes they
want to split the bill but they've been
on the cocktails all night well you only
had one small beer behold the power of
the beer devil when the waiter or
waitress brings your drink and places it
on your beer mat they add a mark with a
pen it's like your own private drinks
tab and at the end you can pay for
whatever is on your individual beer mat
[Music]
modern life is hectic and sometimes feel
like the action never stops if you're
looking for a time
noisy activities like DIY playing loud
music or even recycled glass at a bottle
bank a rule ban on Sundays even the
streets and city centers are eerily
quiet because it's illegal for most
shops and supermarkets to open I know
what you're thinking what do you do on a
Sunday if you run out of cheese it's a
tough one but sometimes you have to make
sacrifices for a little bit of peace and
quiet those were our favorite German
life hacks tell us if we've missed
anything and see you next time for more
inside tips on meet the Germans
you